Imagine that you and a prospective homeowner,
I have entered a contract,
you agree to sell and the prospective homeowner agrees to buy your home for
$500,000 the buyer breaches,
but with no trouble,
you quickly reach an identical agreement with another purchaser for $500,000.
You are in exactly the same position you expect it to be in despite the first
buyer's breach.
If you intuitively think you wouldn't be able to get much in the way of damages.
If you sued the first buyer for breach of contract,
you'd be correct.
Today though,
we're going to discuss a special concept in contract law,
which would allow recovery in a somewhat similar scenario where there is a lost
volume seller.
We will examine this concept by looking at a case called locks the wade.
It was decided by the New Jersey,
uh,
a New Jersey Superior Court in 1955.
After that,
we will discuss important provisions of the uniform commercial code that deal
with damages in the case of buyer breach,
including damages for lost volume sellers.
And in part two of this video we'll consider some hypothetical scenarios to
which we'll try to apply even coming up with numbers as answers,
uh,
for damages under these provisions.
Jerry locks was in the business of leasing music equipment.
He contracted to lease a Juke box to the defendant Gerald Wade for two years.
Lockwood provide records and replace the worn out parts on the jukebox.
He and Wade would split the profits and Wade with wade pain lock and minimum of
$20 per week.
Weighed the lessee repudiated the agreement before the jukebox was installed and
locks lease the equipment to others but he sued wade for breach of contract and
recovered $836 and amount representing the $20 per week for the two years he
would have received that he would have received if the contract had been
performed minus the cost lock would have had to put in the jukebox box and to
maintain it weighed appealed.
He argued that because the plaintiff was able to lease the equipment elsewhere,
he hadn't really lost those two years of profits to the extent he owed anything.
Wade argued he only owed the amount that remained after the mounted gained from
the leases were taken into account considering our home sale example again,
suppose a court awarded you the full purchase price for the first buyer's breach
even though you'd completed the sale with the different buyer.
Wade argued this was essentially what happened in this case.
The court disagreed it explain that locks had many jukeboxes to sell or rent,
where in our earlier hypothetical you only had one house you could sell locks
had many jukeboxes.
Moreover,
locks had argued that quote locations were very hard to get.
There weren't many people seeking to lease the equipment because of this ample
supply and limited demand.
If weighted kept his promise and and uh,
least the jukebox equipment lock still would have been able to Elise additional
loop,
a jukebox equipment to the same people who wanted the equipment.
After Wade breached,
he would have realized the profits from both agreements.
Thus the court concluded quote,
whereas here a plaintiff less or agrees to lease an article of which the supply
in the market is for practical purposes not limited,
then the law would be depriving him of the benefit of his bargain.
If on the breach of the agreement it required his claim against the lessee to be
reduced by the mount,
he actually did or reasonably could realize on a relenting of the article if the
lessee were uh,
if the,
if the first lease were breached quote,
he should have the benefit of both bargains unquote.
Does it matter not just that the supply of jukebox equipment is high,
but the number of people looking to lease the equipment is low with the same
result obtained if that demand had to outpace the available equipment?
Yes,
it matters.
This short side of the market controls the amount of,
uh,
of a good that is sold when there are more people wanting to buy widgets,
then,
uh,
then there are widgets to be sold.
The short supply will determine the amount sold.
Conversely,
if there are fewer people looking to buy a car,
then cars to be sold,
then the short demand side of the market will determine the amount sold.
Undergraduate economics is about finding the equilibrium price where supply
equals demand,
but in disequilibrium it's the short side of the market that determines how much
will be sold.
If there are fewer perspective,
less ease of Jukeboxes,
then there are jukeboxes to be leased.
Those prospective lessees determine the quantity of jukebox sold.
This is the circumstance the court found that supply was greater than demand,
so that Wade's breach impacted the volume that Loc was ultimately able to sell
and so lock was entitled to lost volume damages.
By contrast,
if the number people seeking jukeboxes was greater than the number available for
leasing the same number of juke boxes,
all of them would be least regardless of Wade's preach,
there would be no lost volume and so lock would not be entitled to damages.
Another way of thinking about this is to ask whether Wade's breach was a but for
cause of Locke's renting the Juke box equipment to a subsequent lessees.
Lost volume.
Damages should only be a warden worded if the breach was not a but for cause of
the lease or sale of a good to another lessee or buyer.
We can also formulate the test differently but equivalently asking whether the
breach was a but for cause of the change in the less orders,
volume lost volume damages should only be awarded if the breach is a but for
because of a change in the seller's volume.
Importantly,
it is the breaching lessees a burden to prove that there was no lost volume in
these cases.
Section two seven Oh eight of the UCC is the provision of that,
uh,
of the code that deals with the seller's damages in the case of a buyer's not
acceptance or repudiation of the contract.
What the,
what happened in this case two seven Oh eight one provides the standard UCC
measure of damages.
Quote.
The measure of damages for non acceptance or repudiation by the buyer is the
difference between the market price at the time and place for tender and the
unpaid contract price together with any incidental damages but less expenses
saved in consequence of the buyer's breach.
In other words,
if the market price of the goods at the specified performance time and place is
less than the amount specified in the contract,
the seller can recover the difference,
but if the market price is the same two seven oh eight one wouldn't provide
damages for the seller.
This is where it's two seven oh eight subparagraph two comes in this provision.
States quote,
if the measure of damages provided in subsection one is inadequate to put the
seller in as good a position as performance would have done,
then the measure of damages is the profit which the seller would have made from
full performance by the buyer.
Together with any incidental damages,
due allowance for cost reasonably occurred and do credit for payments or pro
proceeds of resale.
Sellers in Locke's position who for practical purposes have unlimited quantities
of their goods and who resell goods.
After a party's repudiation for the same price as that offered,
those goods to the repudiating party can claim their damages,
which under sub par paragraph one are going to be basically zero.
They can claim that those damages are inadequate to put them back in the
position they would have been in,
had the repudiation not occurred.
So we're now going in the next,
uh,
video,
part two of this module.
We'll go and,
and go ahead and apply.
See how section two seven Oh eight applies in other circumstances.